So let's talk about the Multiple-Writer part of
it. Note that it could be multiple user
data structures present in a given page X.
If that is the case, the programmer probably
has different locks for accessing different portions of
the data structures that happened to all fit
within this page X. So it is conceivable that when all of this was going on.
There was another processor, let's say P4, and
a thread that is running on the processor
P4 got a completely different lock, let's say
L2. And it is accessing some data structure that
happens to be in the same page X. This is perfectly fine. The DSM software Is
not going to do anything in terms of the
diffs that it has created with respect to the
page X because of lock acquisition L. That's
completely different set of actions compared to a different lock acquisition,
say L2. So if in fact that other thread that is running on P4
executed in parallel with P1, got its lock, say L2,
and modified x. When P2 gets its lock L, the liaison
software is going to bring the dif only from the previous users of the same lock
L. P4 was not using L. It was using L2 even though it accessed the same page.
And modifying a different portion of that page.
And therefore the DSM software is going to assume
that that change made by P4 to x is irrelevant so far as P2's critical section
is concerned. So that's the important thing,
and that is where the multiple writer coherence
protocol semantic comes in. That Simultaneously the
same page could be modified by several different
threads on several different processors. And that
is perfectly fine, so long as they're using
different locks. So the association between the set of changes to a page Is only
to specific lock which is being used to govern that critical section and this
is the reason why this is called a Multiple-Writer Coherence Protocol. And we
saw how this Multiple-Writer Coherence Protocol
lives in concert with LRC to reduce
the amount of communication that goes on
in executing critical sections of an application.